pft on yahoo sports peter king mike
floria some of the biggest stories in
the nfl there's none bigger right now
than
the dak prescott injury a gruesome and
uh just horrifying situation for a
quarterback who doesn't have a long-term
deal
we don't know what his future is going
to be surgery's been performed he's
already home from the hospital and on
monday
cowboys ceo stephen jones called dak
press got the face of the franchise so
well the fans face of the franchise
peter still be employed by the franchise
in 2021
mike i think he will uh i think there's
two things to keep an eye on here in the
next
i'd say week or so number one is there
any infection that sets in
the same way it did with alex smith that
led to all the 18
surgeries for alex smith and now one of
the great comebacks
in nfl history um and
let's just assume optimistically
that there are no complications that
there are no infections
you wouldn't think they would have sent
them home from the hospital if there was
a chance
for an infection but we'll see so let's
just assume
that this is as has been reported
somewhere between a four and eight month
recovery period
with obviously a very very important
bone
to a quarterback who's got to move
around a lot and who's got to set his
feet and throw the football
so what we're going to assume mike is
that he's going to be okay
for opening day 2021
and if that is the case i think there's
a there's a factor at play that nobody
really considers
and that is the outpouring of love
and affection and deep respect
for dak prescott not just from the 52
other guys in his locker room or his
coaching staff
i i've been stunned to see everybody
around the league in
other sports uh you know
all over dallas uh everything
is oh man we feel for you this is awful
this is terrible
i've never seen a more empathetic
response
to an injury mike in in a long time
that i've seen toward dak prescott and
so
i think the cowboys realize this they
know
what an asset deck prescott is to their
franchise as a leader
and a player and mike i believe
that even if they don't get a contract
done
they will re-up him in a bad situation
for them cap wise with the cap going
down
to 175 million next year they will re-up
him
even if it takes him 37 million
yeah and that's the key they have until
late february to do a long-term deal
they can negotiate it now they just
can't sign it until after the season
ends
but if they can't work it out the
ultimate leverage for dak is to say
franchise tag me again i'm guaranteed
37.68 million
next year regardless of where the cap
goes and as you said it will be
likely as low as 175 million and
uh the alternative let the market
determine my value and peter i've looked
around at the teams and you
project forward who's going to be
looking for quarterbacks and we don't
even need to go any farther than the nfc
east because
if the giants and offensive coordinator
jason garrett
if washington if maybe even philadelphia
would get a crack at dak prescott they
would crack open the vault
and possibly offer more than the cowboys
that's all the more reason for the
cowboys
to make sure that never happens if it
takes 37.68
if there's no guarantee he's going to be
healthy for week one we just have to do
it
yeah and the one other thing i think to
consider mike is it's not just dak
prescott competing against ayer
it's dak prescott competing against
three top 10
quarterbacks in the draft uh next april
so you know it's one thing if you're
let's say the
new york giants and you have the first
pick in the draft
i mean what would you do and i'm not
saying you wouldn't
go hard after dak prescott if you're
disillusioned with daniel jones
what i am saying is that you know
contractually financially and in all
ways
you might rather have trevor lawrence
but again that's only one team
i think they're gonna be suitors lined
up to take a good shot at dak prescott
there's gonna be more teams looking for
quarterbacks than there are trevor
lawrence's
and if dak gets to the open market we're
gonna find out what he's really worth
and that may be the thing that keeps the
cowboys from letting it happen
that's it for this edition of pft on
yahoo sports we'll see you next time
[Applause]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports